oh yes if that coffee hello hello happy
Wednesday
middle of the week Wednesday not gonna
lie gonna be honest with you all it's
still updating its got like two minutes
two minutes but we figure some people
were like come on hurry up start it so
instead you get to hell now see us talk
for like the next two minutes as we
basically do what we do in production
which is we stretch it out just buy some
time two minutes stretch that dough out
so yeah Borland's three trailer came out
like another trailer came out this
morning yeah with me had more care like
it basically did like a character kind
of reveal yeah it like broke down the
upcoming like four player characters and
then they also had the release date
which is September 13th yeah which was
leaked and now confirmed leaked and now
confirmed and then it's epic it's gonna
be a six month I think epic exclusive I
go back and forth on that I at first I
was like man I don't get what people are
so mad about this and then I'm like okay
I kind of get it now like we're I think
at first do I I saw I think I just saw
the people who are like it's not on
Steam I'm mad and I'm like but then it's
like well the problem is that like I do
think games should be available for
everywhere and I do think the epic store
lacks features yes so so that's the part
where I'm like well actually it's the
part of the epic stores like dude
there's no like it's like like cloud
save or like yeah yeah so I'm guessing
you're talking about the same thing I
saw this morning which is like they did
this chart comparison of like this is
why it's actually bad that it's like on
the epic store and not on Steam and
they're like it's like this huge kind of
list and of like a breakdown of like all
the features that steam has that epic
doesn't and it's like oh like cloud
saves as you mentioned is pretty big
right and there's a whole bunch of other
things and so I have my issues with
steam like I think they're like Store
page is just like a garbage fire as far
as like they just like litter they
haven't really like and updated their
like you I either I definitely think you
know like Steam or epic seems to be
updating or seems to be incentivizing
like a better deal as far as like how
much money like the devs are getting
versus like the store page so I get that
some of their Oh what is no no okay okay
I was like how are you gonna add minutes
when it's actually done that's some
stuff here look I'm just gonna show you
that it's it's done it's loaded into
things they're here I'll do the settings
now yeah look at that oh yes we'll do
full screen smooth I can't even read
that holy so now I can frame lock well
do 60 yeah it's our subtitles people
want to see that so welcome to stable
music for streaming that's nice okay
smile live thank y'all for tuning in
live Monday to Friday 11:00 a.m. we're
gonna check out some Borderlands Game of
the Year Edition came out today for all
those you know if you had Borderlands
you just get the update right you do so
if you if you don't on PC you get it for
free which is really cool
allow that access and otherwise you can
buy it on ps4 and xboxone
for 30 bucks yeah if you want to get it
physically the only way to get it fit a
physical copy is look at that from they
have an exclusive like physical copy if
you're the kind of person who kiss so
Christoph we had to like get like how
did you get the other version because it
basically your steam had to like the old
one it does if you're familiar with the
way like say Bioshock did it like it
just adds like a second version to yours
to your steam page so you'll have by
Borderlands game in your Edition and
then you'll have Borderlands Game of the
Year Edition enhanced it'll say and
that's the one you want to click on we
need enhance pantsed yeah because
basically you kind of had the same thing
earlier which I think someone had
mentioned where I think it's Christophe
that you're like oh this is actually the
old version stuff yeah I clicked on it
and I was like oh and then we had to
install another we basically had to
install another game basically yeah so
here we go so here we go they added
shift codes in I don't remember that
shift codes were like this thing that
bad in like Borderlands 2 and the
pre-sequel where you would like get
codes for keys that you would then use
to like you'd put it into this like box
and then you would get like random
weapon okay someone wants us to do a
dirty style our dirty arty styled name
I don't know your cell name I don't know
about that so you can do I think I could
import my old Oh stick okay so we could
woo you no way uh why don't we import my
siren okay let's do it
boom BAM done imported easy so I guess
when we start the game now I can oh yeah
this is like this is all new this is the
way like Borderlands 2 you did it we'll
do a second playthrough alright let's do
it
cool play your lilith 1141 I play my
level 40 month butter golem yes the
remaster is out should've been out as of
like four hours ago give or take oh you
don't even have all kinds skip some the
intro though alright achievements do you
look at all those achievements okay so
how are you today
pretty good Wednesday middle the week
trying to get over the hump so to speak
Wednesday hump yeah but other than that
pretty good you know checking this out
with John Luke yeah kind of don't know
what I'm gonna do when Borland stir he
comes out probably gonna play it but
Borland okay so Borderlands 2 made me
super sick like I really wanted to play
it but I don't know what it was it made
me sick which is actually I'm curious if
watching you play is gonna make me sick
so I know that they've added a fov
slider okay which is nice so maybe like
that could help I know like Matt Padgett
would get sick okay well mainly because
doing 2016 actually made me super sick
till I turned off motion smoothing or
something like that yeah I forgot what
option it was in the that I turned off
but I turned it off and was like oh
thank God I wanted to I really wanted to
play that game you know yeah so here we
go these are all my guns hello wait I
have a rifle oh man they totally change
the UI I'm like discovering all this
time we're learning okay so yeah all my
all my skills are still here
that bass the same my guns my equipped
guns yeah my my rifles my I had a
revolver and that is gone so I guess
that didn't carry over and then my
sniper is that's a different sniper than
I had all right
maybe if that's the same shotgun stuff
to do and that is the same right okay
that's weird
whatever we'll stick with it yeah I so I
just played this over the weekend said
raise the fov you animal oh I can do
that I think if we could raise that yeah
I was playing it over the weekend the
original version so this is kind of
interesting to like see all the kind of
quality of life updates the difference
is let's try like 90 looks a little
better alright and do my best to watch
much for you I don't know nothing so far
feels that janky to me I mean all things
considered this is the borderlands 1
right 1 its remastered so oh yeah this
is new they had to some hats we only had
one really good one the macaroni chic
yeah that's uh it's from the one of the
deal sees the the doctor dr. Ned one
it's like a werewolf that where is it
put on these goggles alright
oh dang you do color too yeah you can do
any original let's do like a blue look
never get set it to 60fps locked how
much is it a ps4 I think you said 30 30
I'm pretty sure it's 30 bucks
yeah the UI is mostly the same a little
different they added like some extra
like texture to the health and stuff
which is how many nine don't lie is a
$29.99 29:20 $9.99 okay I'll throw you
the penny and this opening is a little
slow I think it's cool that they added
all this
I'm just kind of big this game like you
got chill run the original game I didn't
have any problems getting it to run on
like modern machines which is nice it's
usually the problem is like in our
settings we have it at 50 we have it at
50 oh we're getting trolled I thought I
decided to all check I thought I set it
to yes it's 60 okay it was 50 Hertz for
the reso
you tricked us mark anyways you're good
well no no I mean cuz cuz you can set
the yeah so we want that yeah but your
FPS was technically I know wait it went
back to back 250 Jesus what happened is
it the monitor then i mighta find out
maybe one clicked too many I think I
clicked it an extra time is what happens
alright see if that improves it yeah
yeah yeah that's that is okay thank you
thank you for letting weirdo that's
weird because you're like I locked it at
60 yeah well yes but yeah it's trying to
like a refresh rate of 50 and that's
weird
yeah I did another game we were not
tricked thank you I think it was um like
2nd row or something did that mmm sick
you haven't played that game in a while
feels like forever
I did my 70 hours and called it a day
yeah I think was like something I want
to go back and um oh did you end up
doing that one ending no okay I never
did I got to I got to the Guardian a
fight not too bad
yeah well so I actually I was watching a
speedrun where he killed him like 40
seconds I think I heard you talking
about it's like sugars and something
else right he used the sugars he used
the the define no that was uh that was
the oh he's like the divine confetti and
the sugar and he killed the corrupted
Monken like did he melted him
this gun is more accurate than it was on
the UH I know because it was literally
just playing it like 10 secs like was
there more kick or something
a little more kick okay thanks so much
loot dude and let's get me a revolver
I'm missing I'm missing one so see
compared to god this you I don't know if
I like it it's like very different I
just have to get used to it
we'll go with this for now
it's the best crime asking who's the
hottest Borland's character claptrap
right oh yeah absolutely
or no no that new uh little turret
walking turret walking gun with legs
yeah
I'm really curious how that's actually
gonna function as like a weapon cuz I'm
just like why would I do that when I
could you shoot them
does it have 4k yes okay they added 4k
like textured support and then they've
also updated Borderlands 2 and the
pre-sequel today with 4k texture II
support as well on PC and on console I
think the only difference is that the
console versions get like HDR and the PC
versions dull which is HDR is still
weird on PC though like I've I've had it
where I I have my PC hooked up to my 4k
TV which does HDR support I turn on the
HDR and then it just like doesn't work
right and I'm like maybe there's like a
thing I need to go and like set but I
don't know HDR with PCs are still just
like weird
nice I mean it looks mostly the same I
would say that there's like a more
defined like blind oh hey it's remember
when he left her on the stage oh geez
that was a fun one that whole press the
whole conference or whatever press
conference whatever it was that was
weird
Jared still wearing Carlson's do like in
lobster Hunter yeah that's the case
we're like the dev implementation of
HDR's weird yeah you can still yeah it's
on the devs to actually do the HDR
properly and in that game HDR is not
very good what type of TV do I have I
have a Samsung LED very budget or like
budget efficient TCL it was I got ok I
remember I got it I got a fairly cheap
like 700 cuz it was like a black so I
better than my mind was like 300 I went
for the cheap this and then mine was on
sale it's like a Black Friday thing and
that was like because I was like you
know I'm gonna get it and then I won't
need to get another TV for a while my
parents still have a neighbor like 1080p
they got it like it's still going strong
and I think only now are they finally
like yeah we you know
well maybe switch over to 4k but I mean
that thing lasted there's not really a
reason okay though right like you're not
watching 4k TV for the most part and
like my you're gonna do 4k blu-ray so so
so that's why it's cuz my dad really
loves like watching like 4k blu-rays
okay and that's like the big reason he
wants to swap over well it's not that
expensive in order to get to know it
depends on like how high of a quality I
think I think he was just waiting
for liable to get cheaper and he was
like hey this like TV is fine so uh
here's the the loot box I have 75 keys
because I played the original day of
games they gave them to me so again you
and I don't care let's do it ain't no
thing 74 more oh look at me what do I
get
Oh static machine gun let's try 1 hostak
machine I didn't realize the apex
legends was yeah yeah that's pretty good
well get reloads a little slow but well
second LMG right oh he didn't want the
other one well not I should probably
grab a kazoo you use the key on it
exactly the whole thing with the keys
was always weird because it does go to
your level something like we're down oh
wait to my max level before I use the
keys like it's just a waste I'm wasting
Bobbie Jenkins asking so what is
remastered about this game we're like
what's so they've redone the textures to
be 4k I mean it looks very similar I
think it's just kind of like cleaning a
lot of them up they definitely look
sharper for sure I could tell you that
so like yeah I don't like run on modern
displays nice GUI it's been over honed
up and overhauled there's a mini-map now
you can see that was not there in the
original so that is new they have I feel
like the weapon handling feels a little
bit nicer there's like some more options
like fov that kind of thing the way they
show angel looks different now today
they redid that help that little robot
the remaster release date it's actually
out today boots not today or even you
can play it yeah if you have the first
one on PC you just get a free if you
want to purchase it it's
basically 30 bucks I know they added a
split screen on the console versions
that's cool
not on PC which is I mean I guess I make
sense cuz like it's probably very little
useful muscle what if you want a split
screen just as a concept
yeah I know but I still I'm like why not
like just give it to him just give it to
him yeah I think it's or it's just like
it's a good way to like update it for
modern machines I mean like I said I had
no issue playing the old game on modern
systems but you know it's a little
outdated in some ways I think this is
like here's an easy way for people to
play the game if you've never played it
and you're interested or you're you know
just wanna replay it this is like a good
way to do it and like I said if it's
special on PC it is for me so that's
really nice mm-hmm and I think the game
actually holds up surprisingly well
I'm was kind of like worried like oh
maybe I'm
enjoy this much but I'm playing it over
the weekend I thought it was a pretty
fun time still um where is it
er cat says what are your feelings on
Borland's three epochs store exclusive
six months exclusive kind of talked
about that earlier um where I think my
concern is more just like the lack of
features that epic has compared to seem
compared to steam I mean like stuff like
friends list and like easy access to
like it's just so bare-bones right like
yeah well has all these things that
they've kind of like slowly built over
time it's like I have my issues with
steam for sure and I'm all for
competition but I feel like epic epics
current like offering for the consumer
is very bare-bones so I think that's
certainly going to I don't know yeah
problems for me like the only thing I
see as the opposite spectrum of it is
like that you know there's there's
obvious reasons why a lot of companies
are picking the epic store over steam
they get a bigger cut to get a bigger
cut which obviously usually offering
them additional money as well to be an
exclusive yeah so like it's really hard
to pass some of that stuff up especially
since I don't know in this case is what
six-month exclusive but yeah maybe maybe
somewhat like losing some of the
features and things that steam does
provide you know is that gonna bite them
in the butt down the road I don't know
like just for my community standpoint
but I have to look at that list again to
really understand all the things that
are kind of like lacking or missing but
the cloud safe thing is pretty tough to
not have and then like the friends
Lucien things like that for sure I don't
know but maybe this will force team to
kind of like have to deal with like
another like platform for like the first
time in a long time where like you know
maybe it maybe it'll UPS teams game you
know what that's my hope right like
best-case scenario is like the epic
story forces seem to actually like work
be better yeah yeah that back a lack of
that competition yeah this is like no I
don't like it's changed it's like too
big now like I kind of like be able to
easily like read the like it was more
just like text-based not as much like
this giant like blocky like here's all
these stuff and I don't know is it
because you're used to the other way or
because I'm used to it like cuz I just
played a bunch of it over the weekend
but I'm just like oh like mark says
rippling vsync I could turn I can try
turning on yeah I think there is a
little bit of tear it changed it again a
50 maybe it's the monitor it's the
monitor 50 that doesn't make sense
though cuz I bought these ones because
it's what Michael had I recommend I'm I
just went to like a weird resolution
that has now no signal for the no it's
good it's good
it's back don't worry it's fine I'll
turn a sink and I'll have to go double
check on the monitor but this was the
one that was recommended by truck behind
instead the higham see if that works Oh
lose it for a second and back
so if you guys are curious that's a mage
well not your card it just goes right to
50 yeah maybe it's the line pass strange
that is turned on vsync now hopefully
that helped little bit box I was asking
why we're playing good offered she he's
watching and he has a level of 41
character I guess he could I wouldn't be
opposed to that
check your monetary settings maybe it's
set to 50 yeah maybe it's something to
check after marks are saying guys main
point of the remaster is that it's for
consoles because Borland's one is not on
current gen only war lens 2 and the
pre-sequel the pc version just gets the
smaller version yeah it's definitely
it's mainly meant for constants for sure
i think the pc is more just like hey
like we added some benefits that happen
and we're gonna give it that's why
they're getting too free for pc because
it is like ultimately just like quality
of life improvements and it's not a you
know i think players would be kind of
the rifle is pretty interesting in the
sense that like I just see it coming out
of the barrel but then it almost does it
feel like it's hitting them but it is
yeah
visually it's just right right right
since it's already level 41 yeah I
imported my character that I was playing
over the weekend on the original version
that's nice that they'll Chi do that I
know otherwise it's mostly the same game
like I think they the only thing I know
that they really changed was apparently
they maybe they changed the final boss
because the final boss in original game
was like a pushover and they apparently
made it
they to make it more their barrack words
were that we wanted to make it more epic
although I and I would have to see other
people's but I was watching the IGN
review they did for this and they were
saying they actually made the boss
easier is what IGN was saying like
actually it's like way easier now so if
anything it's like more disappointing
I'm curious if other people felt the
same right but yeah they were just like
pointing right at it and just she's just
melting in I was like wow all right
[Music]
[Applause]
did you ever play Borderlands I didn't
play Borderlands I played as much as a
as I could tolerate Borland's to in
terms of just like I would have to play
in spurts because I would get like
motion sick yeah and I just oh do it so
like I really wanted to because I had
missed the boat on one and I was like
now I'm gonna have play too it's like
totally up my alley you know it's like
got like crazy loot and kind of the og
one but I guess yeah it's sort of what
started the like modern looters yeah
trend and like as I cool like I want to
do this but I just like couldn't do it
my my body wouldn't let me pass the bar
yeah so hopefully gonna play three yeah
were you playing it on I'm curious what
it is for you because when Matt said it
was like an FLV thing for him recall to
be honest I just remember like playing
for you know actually one time is I'm
just going like oh I can't I need to
stop or I need to like look away yeah
like I need to like stare at the ceiling
for a couple like you know like 30
seconds to a minute or something and
then I'd be like alright cool I could
get back in and try again and then like
15 minutes later or whatever it is just
make me sick again I was like I can't do
this so then at some point I just like I
I tried I gave it a go and I can but
maybe I should have googled how to make
the borderlands to make me less motion
sick because I think I did something
like that for doom it's like oh sweet
just turn this off and that'll fix it
right everything was fine yeah there's
always a couple culprits fov motion blur
I think those motion blur for doom now
that I think about and it doesn't really
have much motion blur
box nine asking if we read the article
about anthem stuff from kotaku I don't
really read it I kind of like have heard
some things but I just feel bad for the
yeah I read I read the whole thing it's
very good yeah
I just feel bad for the the it sounded
like that was a really rough time for
some of the staff and I where it sounded
like the the usual culprits
mismanagement yeah you know like not a
great work environments poor leadership
oh yeah I mean or is it Jorge if you
rather play on showdown more power to
you play but thank you for tuning in
no I finished doom crime I was able to
turn something off it's it's Borderlands
that I didn't actually figure and make
it through yeah I couldn't do it well
like I said I didn't really try to do
things to fix it back then wars with
doom I was like actively trying to
figure out what the hell was like
causing me to feel the way I was good
afternoon
Lani Rick's plays how you doing
basically yeah I'm curious how many
people are actually gonna go back as a
replay or new folks or new folks they
are like are there anyone he's like
never played Borderlands or didn't play
one specifically they're like back along
but I'm curious wonder if this is
something like I mean again since I
didn't play it but like you know maybe
it's something you get your kids to play
because they would have never played a
Borderlands and you can kind of split
screen with them or something sure well
maybe not like kid kids but you know
what I mean like sure I'm gonna give it
a try with my uh my golf game be oh
we've been trying like co-op games like
together and we played we played
Resident Evil 5 recently which was
actually kind of fun go actually
surprisingly good because she really
likes resident before okay so that's why
she wanted to try five she's like oh I'm
familiar I know how to play this
and it was actually a really fun time I
need a break I need twist is asking hey
dudes how is the game because I won't
say the first part of its name it's
pretty good
I feel like throw away some crude aid ii
need some space I remember this being a
Fame with hello welcome good morning
yeah it's it's good I mean hates
Borderlands yeah but it but it feels
good like I think there are some like
subtle tweaks to like the way it feels
on like like Mouse aiming on like for
like PC and stuff it feels it feels a
little bit better like I remember that
original PC poor it was I don't mean
sold worst PC port but lacking like not
not as not up to par as you expect I
remember they made a really big deal
about at Borland's to having like a
really good PC port which it did yeah
like they were like we're gonna put in a
lot of effort into it so this feels like
they've just kind of brought this
version up to snuff with like sort of
what you now expect from a PC port of a
borderlands game is remaster coming to
steam we're actually playing on Steve
yeah we're playing on Steam we're
playing right now if you already on the
game you get it for free and as you've
done in this playthrough you've imported
your character imported my character
I lost my revolver which was a little
weird but other than that all everything
else has been everything else and
preserve my sniper changed I don't
remember it being in a like an electric
sniper yeah but that's fine boy asking
me did I get motion sick in other games
the only other game I vividly remember
getting motion sick too when I was
younger was Tarak oh man
Tarak messed me up I could not watch my
friend play to rock it made me super
sick but I mean you could say that about
a
multiple kind of like FPS games like I
can play them but man I can't watch some
people play some of them I can't I can't
specifically think of one off the top of
my head I just remember you know just
being over the shoulder like trying to
watch someone and be like oof
I'm getting sick but that's because you
don't know where they were gonna go and
that's I don't know part of it I guess
let's see 1 billion guns huh well that's
for Borderlands to be right yeah well
I'm just checking if my yes we're
playing on PC what are your PC specs uh
we have a nerd pen high nine i seven
eighty seven hundred k we have a 1070
and 32 gigs of ram that's pretty much
all you need to know i guess if you own
it on Steam you just get a free kind of
like you just get a free update or
there's like another version that you
have to install basically yeah sorry I'm
just going through my up on your here
I'm Luke Worcester doesn't see a
difference
it's a subtle difference for sure I mean
you did like a massive overhaul in the
visuals it just kind of naturally said
some of the UI is different the UI is
different that mini-map wasn't there
before I think there's more thicker like
black lines on like guns and characters
you said like you kind of feel like the
handling of the weapons are a little bit
better feels a little bit better and so
then some of the some of the menus are
different for better for worse yep the
menus are differents there is uh you can
like lock your weapons now if you want
which is nice or you can mark them as
junk maybe like junk junk which is
that's new that was the thing for morons
to that they've added so that's nice
there's purple the highest tier try
remember purple fire in Portland
I think gold
hi 999 hundred k with the 2080 TI for
the win that's a pretty good rig thing I
don't know more on this game I mean here
if we like play it in 4k we like there's
one beating 4k yeah that's why we don't
know like it really father not a big
deal
now
nailed it
oh is that the melee yeah yeah yeah
don't mention they changed the way angel
looks did you
hmm somebody Scaggs somebody's test -
that's a lot of the opening of who's
James killing Skaggs someone said that
they still enjoy killing Skaggs quite a
bit I yeah it was one of those things
were playing over the weekend I was like
I thought yeah it holds up pretty well
you're into the looting and shooting
yeah that was the other thing though
it's like it's so much overwhelming
amount to loot this it's a lot of like
getting we going to figuring out if it's
better anyway yeah I definitely think
they struck a better balance in the
other game playing it over the weekend
it was like most of the time it would
just be like garbage yeah that's a lot
of me like filling up my inventory
selling it all doing that again and very
rarely what I felt like gear that's what
you wanted to I felt like they they kind
of fix that and the sequels I don't know
if they really changed anything here
like that
one Anya
he was angry
so slow but it's like an LMG that was
always a thing they were like guns you'd
get that's like it's got really high
fire rate and then you like pull it out
and they'd like very slowly
nope no no nope nope nope I'm not using
this gun that reload is way too slow
Auto mutant is apparently not a fan of
the portal series and it wants to know
why respects it tolerates this game
series but hey video games I think some
people like it for different reasons I
really like it for just like the Luton
in the shooting I find it really
satisfying and fun he said you back then
back in the day you enjoyed kind of like
the I don't know vo and the story I did
I was like really in support I I was
reeling a boy lines too and I like
distorting the characters I don't know
how much that holds up for me personally
I know that's a big thing a lot of
people really like the characters in
their humor yeah I know area does well
we playing Borderlands 1 I think it
holds up pretty well because it is
actually fairly reserved its minimal in
its serene characters but what's there I
do think is good I've got to replay
Borderlands 2 so I'll kind of see there
you go there's ZX degeneration you lose
a succat playthrough humor
at the wrong time yeah you're good yeah
I'm curious like if replaying - if I
fall like purple purple puncher shotgun
stripe over fire out 20300 just way more
damage I'm damn that though and then the
glorious massacred no problem here just
fighting a boss yeah LMG oh he dead easy
so dead
ooh fire gun yeah yeah yeah clipper -
clip try oh yeah this is like a weird no
shot hey at least it reloads pretty
quick I just hate like look at that oh
the iron sight the lack of iron so awful
we were hitting it laughs no thank you
class mod I think I'm a Firefly right
now I don't think my class mod is
properly a cook with my skills I don't
think I paid attention to that too much
what do you prefer the division or
Borderlands I probably if you were to
ask me and if I couldn't like assuming I
didn't get sick playing Borderlands I'd
probably say Borderlands only because I
honestly don't think I like cover
shooters and I'm not into military
shooters like a military leader shooter
I'm just not into it I definitely like
the aesthetic important Lance more than
division that's the thing I'm most
curious about Borderlands 3 is sort of
like how are they what are they gonna
bring that's new do it because it's like
hey and the times Borderlands like we
said was the loot shooter that sort of
like started the whole craze sense
Borderlands 2 and the pre-sequel
that decimal one that destiny - division
1 division 2 those you know like big
games that have evolved it I'm not
saying boy Lannister he needs to like
just sort of copy those games or like
those need to figure out what those what
the good things they added
for like that never learned yeah exactly
like what are the good things that those
games have figured out that are worth
never it makes sense to bring over to
Borderlands so I'm just very curious
like what that would cuz I don't know I
go back and forth on leg I don't know if
it's four lines test leaves like a hub
world or anything like always online
kind of thing maybe maybe not it depends
on how they handle it
Raphael II it is out on PC if you guys
are trying to if you're trying to get it
yeah I think someone asked if like are
we gonna play three year play three yeah
probably
I'll play are you guys up for Berlin
three I mean yeah I don't know check it
out I'm definitely up for it it's coming
up it's coming out I like it what is
usually uh well I guess it's Q for like
the beginning of Q for early well it's I
guess we'll see kind of in the coming
months yeah III would right now it's
like very light for the rest of the year
like there is announced yeah exactly I
think I think there's like games that
you think are probably gonna come out
this year but then you're not really
sure like what like dude do we know do
maternal like we have no record like I
haven't said but I feel like that game
should come out this year and then like
the other like kind of mystery game is
like his last of us to I highly doubt
cyberpunk but why not right definitely
everyone who's like star points
definitely does here in like okay yeah
but the first - I feel like have a
chance like have a jerk ants right if
they were not to come up this year it'd
be like really nice yeah for sure and
I'm trying to think of like what else
there could be like I don't know me what
do you think about ghosts is Tsushima
you think that said this year or next
year kind of thing I don't know I feel
like they haven't seen much of that okay
I can't really tell think what else oh
you got some gags Anya Maloney scag
Emily
judgment yeah judgment comes out this in
the summer yeah she was summer there's
all that like Nintendo stuff there's a
ton a Nintendo stuff come out in the
summer but the fall falls pretty light
yeah there just hasn't been a lot of
like confirmed like dates and things
like that but um we'll see usually more
news comes out of like III and things
like that or like I don't know if
there's any there's games come to I
think in August and right
who knows what Sony's gonna do if
they're what like you know since they're
not gonna be at e3 are they doing
something they've been doing that like
what the state of the state of play that
first was a pretty pretty disappointing
good there's a lot of there's a lot of
VRS VR a
I'm all for VR I actually don't I'm into
the VR I've been her judge eyes and
immediately rights yeah you got days
gone which is in April this end of this
month mkn to this month
those are the two big April games if I
can recall maybe this is why like works
better on like controller but like I'm
mouse and keyboard I'm actually like
super not into it
that bounty board we're trying to check
out game releases but those two that I
just mentioned were the bigger ones for
April but it's been a pretty good 2019
to be honest so far a lot of good high
quality games coming out someone's
asking about the Borderlands 2 update
with that brought so that's just 4k like
textures support I think it's like 4k I
think it brings HDR its kind of it it's
just more of like an enhanced pack it's
not like changing anything about those
games so what I have from for April from
GameSpot and I'm sure there's maybe
possibly more games in this but yeah EDF
iron rain Earth Defense Force April 11th
that's on ps4 you have an O 1800 PC
April 16th right new yeah and then
there's Final Fantasy 10 and our Final
Fantasy X and x-2 HD remastered on the
Xbox one and switch Dragon's Dogma dark
arisen on switch that's the 23rd and
then Mortal Kombat's on the 23rd yeah a
box-boy plus box girl 26 same day as
days gone 26 and then you have final
fantasy 12 the zodiac age on Xbox one
and switch at the end of April yeah
other than that oh yeah rage 2 in May
yeah yeah that's all before e3 though
yeah Super Mario maker that's a June TBA
judgment again in June that's post e3 as
well
you have Youngblood Wolfenstein
Youngblood July control and August I
believe and yeah then it kind of gets
we'll see yeah after that no idea
but yeah interesting to see what's gonna
come out of a three and I mean like kind
of games just do that do the thing where
it's like we show it to you and by the
way it comes out to you for kind of
thing right right
you think Sony will announce a ps5
mister the baby people are speculating
they're not doing III is because they're
actually prepping for like a big their
own kind of thing big conference where
they're gonna be like ps5 this happening
yeah I don't know though
I wouldn't be shocked if they did but I
don't know how much like info you'll get
same with like I don't know how much
info we're going to get about Xbox ones
like new console which you you could you
could potentially see at e3 right like
we don't like because like when they
first did Xbox one X which was like
Scorpio right they like didn't really
show much they didn't talk about it
Project Scorpio and then they you know
showed like diving into like a like Xbox
and like it like looking at like it's a
motherboard or something like that and I
just don't know what cuz I feel like at
this point everything they have would
probably be for the next generation
right like yeah like Halo incident and
you know yeah yeah I guess all the
studios that they just bought they're
definitely making games for the next
system right so it's like gears 5 is
maybe I don't know marquee actually just
brought that up you said when is gears 5
coming uh thinks that it's this year but
I want it badly I mean they did kind of
show a lot they really kind of like a
show the last me they kind of messed
that presentation up though that portion
of the presentation cuz like you did
this thing we're like I don't even
remember I just remember they kind of
bashed it because they had like the
Funko pop Gears of War they had like
something else so they started like
Funko pop which was like gross
okay I'm checked out yeah then they went
to like hey here's the Gears of War XCOM
bands like that looks more interesting
huh I don't know why you started the
Funko pop and then they're like and by
the way through skiers 5 and yeah just
led with gears 5 legend here's 5
and then sandwich the funkopop in the
middle you know yeah ah they knocked me
off that's alright
hey look it's race so yeah like I just
like you kind of had this sour taste in
your mouth of like oh yeah all right
gears and then like oh snap here's five
like alright why didn't you and if you
show me that sin actually really like
that key was five I played for and I
liked it but I it didn't get me like and
that's sort of like jazzed for more
gears but I thought that that trailer
for five actually looked really cool
yeah so here's five I don't know when
it's coming out though
yeah maybe this year like they need
something I don't anything will be
coming this year it's only rumors of dev
kits maybe next year thirty three yeah
like Oh Mario the thing that they could
do is they could do just like the kind
of soft announcement of like that it
like exists but then not really get into
details about like you know what's in it
and like what it can do right and then
they can just get people like kind of
just excited the fact I like okay yeah
we know that it's like finally kind of
like on its way and we'll probably get
more deets you know next year or later
this year kind of thing but who knows I
mean I'm trying to think of like like
you had just mentioned like what are the
games that you know that you would want
to save as you know potential what
console sellers and things like that you
know you might have halo infinite you
know that makes a lot of sense because
all they showed last year was basically
a tech demo right and yeah then you
think about you know PlayStation 5 or
Sony including a pilot what what what
could I foresee as something like that
they they want to launch with right
right like oh this is gonna be the one
that gets people a blood-borne to right
everyone you know Joe would be so sick
yeah but they already shown you a two
and I feel like that's been in
development already right so like I feel
like that game could conceivably come
out this year god I really hope it's not
as long as the first one it's every 26
cyberpunk 2077 is all that matters but
that's a fair one like do you think
there would be like it kind of like an
arms or a
for who can get the exclusive or some
type of exclusive off that or unique
it's just such a big PC thing that like
maybe it doesn't matter Mike so I feel
very confident in saying that game is
not gonna come on the current generation
of hardware yeah no but I'm saying
though for next-gen I'm just sayin you
know did they showed it was it at
Microsoft's last year they did show the
play so Microsoft might have the leg up
there that they might have the leg up I
don't know yeah my guess would be yeah
if I could make it work if the the stars
happen to align you would be like hey
new Xbox a new Playstation whatever
launch game cyberpunk that gets people
to buy and that's what people are gonna
spawn us and saying there's anything
launched with cyberpunk yeah you watch
with that's that's a launch game because
it's like you know obviously the people
are gonna play on PC you're just gonna
play on ya don't have all these people
who are like I don't have I own the
hottest game I need to buy it yeah I
can't play it on my current system cuz
it's just that awesome
I need to have a good reason I
definitely have a good reason that's a
reason to get people to buy any system I
bought this switch because of breadth of
the wild and like for the longest time I
didn't even think it would be a launch
game but then at some point I was like
now it makes so much sense for it to be
a launch game because they need like a
system seller right yeah and that was
like the problem I felt like with ps3
when I bought my ps3 I didn't have a
game that I like I'm a ps4 as well that
game look really good it looked really
good
how does this compare Dalton asking how
does it compare to Borderlands 2
what do you mean as far as like visuals
or or feel I mean I haven't played
Boylan's two in a bit it like I said
it's more in line with Borderlands do
you like that I just some quality life
improvements that puts up to par with
Borderlands 2
mm-hmm as far as well direct prefer
Borland's one or two from like a
gameplay standpoint
okay resogun was a launch title I mean
like that's a smaller one that was a
small one oh yeah I think I prefer
ultimately four lines to I really like
the way like that the variety of
environments for when it's too early
I like bronze one what about that nak
life though huh dude I think I got a
second game is what I is a so what
happened to me was I when I got my
playstation and was almost like hey man
you get like two three games and I was
like ah rapid black flag oh no which was
good which is a good choice and then I
was like it was it was like I did kill
zone and I was like okay do I want like
it was like need for speed or it was
like Mac and I'm like I don't really
like Need for Speed I guess I'm good Mac
I should got any hahaha sauce Harris
take surveys thanks were made all right
let's take a look all right so with Xbox
one you had peggle to think killer
instinct oh yeah Forza Motorsport 5
you're super long life
Dead Rising 3 yet Ryse son of Rome
mm-hmm
Panzer Dragoon may be the hot tip is
just you just wait just wait till
there's a game that you want to actually
plan on it and then that's what you play
yeah all right because that's what
mistake that's the mistake I made on ps3
is I really wanted Final Fantasy 13 but
that game took like how long to come out
like houses and then I never even beat
that game even though I got to like the
likes quote-unquote good part you know
people told me use grenades is stream
lagging or the game the games like
you've been a little laggy we keep going
in like trying this with the settings
it's like dude I I don't know why I keep
switching to 50 Hertz but it's you know
what then I'm gonna lock the frame at 50
and maybe that will fix it
I don't know I've been trying not to
like watch too much daddy it's been a
little hichi
people wandering it is the game I but it
might be something weird with our
monitor because for whatever reason it
won't let us switch over 60 frames it's
just really weird
bring me 60 Hertz 60 Hertz yeah a 50 I'm
the only thing you could do is you could
back out to check the like actual
monitor settings
yeah I'm up it's worth it okay this is
really bothering people
Gundam 572 asking what is your favorite
class from either game mine is
necromancer mech romance is really good
so I like playing the sirens I played
loathe in one and I played my in two and
then I played gauge when she came out a
month later for my second playthrough
and I really really liked gauge a lot
like she's really cool you could break
that game of her like anarchy ability
paired with like a couple certain guns
and shields just absolutely breaks that
game in like the best way fight from
racks the invincible um I don't have
chrome racks on this character
Cromer acts on my soldier we can but I
wouldn't be able to do it probably
because I'm on uni multiple people to be
like Joey says guns er sir come sir Kirk
and secret school Ben says that Mars
really fifty I don't believe it I don't
believe it either
I don't believe it either I don't know
why it's it won't it refuses to go to
sixty we keep trying here let me gun
surgery is school then was trying to
tell me a concern I didn't really like I
was like oh this is name I act axial she
would Africa the the soldier class for
two because he's basically just roll in
but like with a bigger turret and I was
like I'm not like I knew it I didn't
really care for it
two guns at the same time yeah it's
pretty cool be Fox animation says
necromancer made stolen in Borderlands 2
viable first true yeah like a death trap
it was like a so who broke in you just
turned deathtrap bond and it made it a
lot easier for you crimes thinks also
it's possible that maybe the immediate
control panel and set to 50 Hertz weird
miss Briggs I feel like we haven't come
across this issue
that we know of though I don't know
already just never paid attention
nope not miner could also be set to 50
also could just be a bug in the game
could be about other than these Scaggs
yeah keep yelling that's what I want I'm
out got some shells to feed you as he
tries to run away
[Music]
now closer you do another box another
boss not super close I feel like no
worries just curious yeah we could um
people are interested we get like pop
over one of the DLCs or something I feel
like curious the world is your oyster if
people would like to mix it up and see
anything else please let me know use
your ability more I do anymore it's like
but I like the shooting I don't use it
enough I mainly use it just escape
escape or if I'm like I need to go
faster it's taking too long to get to
this place
I definitely preferred my's abilities
and - I thought there was a good greater
variety notes go
come on yeah open wide
there you
what is your a game of the year so far
I'll let y'all bleep answer that first I
think I know what it is I don't I did
you feel like you can surd this question
before maybe unless you you've changed
your stance more recently well my game
of the year was definitely cry but it
might be Sakura oh wow what are we
talking about this while you're playing
SEC your oh yeah but now you're cheating
your mind has changed I like sex
I like sector oh the more I played it
the more I did to my god by the end of
Sakura I was really okay so now it's
it's it's a toss-up between those fear
for you right yes but you're leaning
Seki row right now if you had to answer
a gun to your head I think right now I'd
leave sector out but I want to go back
and play both for more okay Joey
cuphead on switch Cody oh yeah yeah Joey
you gotta fight for it I guess for me
it's apex I just can't stop playing that
game and after playing blackout
yesterday it just reminded me how much
like apex apex is pretty good but I
haven't played the mc5 yet I really want
to after watching all starting to kind
of go through the bloody palace which
isn't even really the like you know core
of that game what seemed like the combat
yeah the combat and just like the
precision and the options available
there I was like oh this is really cool
like I should I should totally play this
and I was joking about that stuff during
my plate or after I finished second row
thinking like the the perfect palate
cleanser after all this kind of
methodical stealth you know combat and
and whatnot and difficulty would be to
play DM C 5 because it's not that that
game isn't difficult it's just that
there's more room for error and
potentially mmm-hmm you would say it
like I I'm just saying like from in
terms of like fighting bosses and
enemies and things like that it's not as
punishing I guess is that fair yeah I
would say the difference between them is
like Sakura you're trying to like master
and beat it doesn't make cry you can
beat Devil May Cry it's more about like
because there's like easy Auto combos
inside yeah and even then I wouldn't say
like the normal difficulties it's not as
hard as I think a lot of people think it
is it's more about like personal
expression and like like pushing
yourself because it's like Secor was
like okay oh I beat this boss dull my
cry it's like I beat that boss can I
beat that boss without taking any damage
to get him a Triple S rank yeah that's
kind of like the the fundamental
difference between those two games and
their priorities so I guess it's like
kind of what you prefer
I thought you go ask you little pick gun
in this stream not in this one that's in
three no sadly no no little was it
called they know like turn on legs likes
gun with legs gun with legs is there
anyone in having trouble with FPS - you
can't go over 20 no we haven't had
problems with the FPS as much as we had
the hurts yeah yeah we're able to get
the framerate
it's just that hurts with the monitors
acting up so we'll have to see after you
know what's going on with what's going
on yeah Mario man says I keep finding
about more hidden stuff in Sec here oh
yeah that's just the nature from
software games
I feel like usually your first
playthrough you just really miss certain
things and then that's kind of there
where the replayability is at I mean
also just having more skills and all
that is kind of why you would replay
just because I don't think you can get
all the skills in your first playthrough
I mean I guess you could if you grind in
a bunch and we're pretty smart about it
but in general I think like playing
through it again is probably how you
kind of get some more skills like I
didn't even get sent beaux-arts and so
super late because I just somehow missed
it it's on the scrub my very first
playthrough I missed Hasina text which
basically has a bunch of moves so yeah
if you didn't know there's like multiple
texts that you can get and you should
get them because they offer
bunch of skills I never got the spear
prosthetic oh I still haven't used that
that's the one thing I want to try a new
game is seeing how that works against do
boo well not just kill boo as well hey
it worked on the Guardian the spear why
apparently if you and your second phase
if you stun him down on the ground
yeah then use the spear and you rip out
the you rip out the bug and then you can
like do massive posture you know what I
watched a speedrunner he managed to
deflect him twice in a row and he got
him to light in like ten seconds he had
him to like two-thirds of his like
posture damage take out on the second
phase and I was like I need to do that
you didn't clean would have thought to
do that though like that the spirit text
itself doesn't like imply imply that it
it very much implies like hey this is
for people that have like armor on like
loosely that you could just rip off yeah
and then there will become a lot weaker
and it's like okay that makes sense like
nothing there would make me ever think
to try that weapon against the Guardian
ape but whatever yeah Eric skip like 10
hours true but then I can't I went back
and did everything so I have for the
most part beat everything that I know of
that exists in the game even like the
side bosses I just haven't got all the
endings like are you know what
technically I haven't been one boss
because one boss is tied to a certain
ending so I guess you could argue that I
haven't beaten that ball sure in which
case I could do that in a new game I
just don't know if I have it in me I
think I'd rather go and play like the
mc5 or something before doing it another
playthrough alright just because I now
it's like as I was talking to a lost
Hondo yesterday knowing that there
aren't too many games coming out in
April or at least not till late April
it's kind of a good time couple weeks
here to catch up on kind of the first
three months of games and like whatever
you've either missed out on or just
haven't had enough time to spend on
but then I somehow find my way and they
out playing a it doesn't help that you
know like I have a few buddies that play
on PCs so like when it's night time
they're like hey let's go play a couple
games and those couple games always ends
up being more than a couple games but I
definitely DMC I definitely want to try
out and play it really does have some
like fighting game mechanics to it of
like just like sorting out your combos
like getting good with a Dodge in the
perianth right and then trying like you
said it's like about getting that triple
s and and trying to maintain the triple
s don't get hit right because I'm who's
like two three rankings once you get hit
yeah but yeah back to Borderlands we are
playing Borderlands game of the year
edition yep okay the remaster which came
out today if you owned it on PC you can
just go and download it it's like a
separate game basically it's not the
just base game even though for some
reason in steam it still calls a game of
the Year Edition but then the the proper
ones I've gained in the Year Edition
enhance enhance that's the version
you're looking for so it's beyond the
game on Steam that's that's what you
look for put the apex down it's really
hard for me to play it it's really hard
James o says despite Randy Pitchford its
best efforts I'm really looking for I
just believe it all right we got an
ounce of borderlands like which we call
like which would call game any like what
am i blanking on this what like a board
game it was a card game it's a card game
and he's like we're gonna do magic all
right I couldn't tell if he was serious
and the whole time was John those two
are plants they're plants play and
luckily he got it on the second go but
I'm curious that he meant to screw up
the first time
but yeah there's not only a lot of
people stoked and excited for uh for 11
3 I'm interested hopefully I can play
without getting the sick the sickness
yeah lay out angry had been team seen
using my style mode they should add that
[Music]
Randi's very serious about his magic oh
yes most people are actually my friend
was telling me yesterday that I met up
with he was like oh dude I've been like
trying to work on my magic and I was
like Magic the Gathering
he's like no no like actual magic but
Magic the Gathering is pretty cool too
[Laughter]
and he was so he was like alright cool
let me show you a couple tricks and I
was like all right you got me kind of
but I could tell his like he wasn't
smooth it cuz their card tricks right
the card tricks are about how about
deceive your eye and like make you not
want to look at the deck and you know
all that stuff working on it yeah he's
working right but I was like dude you
got to smooth it out cuz I can tell like
when you're I don't see him flipping the
card to like keep it like on the top or
whatever but it felt too mechanical in
robotic worried he wasn't really like
tricking me and I was like dude you got
to work on your magic if you're getting
it good at Magic triple-a is asking I
haven't played any borderlands games
where should I start first well I'm I
guess this is a good start you know this
game the addition for one if you enjoy
the just like the concept of the columns
you play on console you can local coast
split-screen co-op you can
yeah I mean see if basically you get a
you get to figure out if you're gonna
play Borderlands 3 or not essentially
because I mean I expect some changes in
differences in Borderlands 3 but I'm
sure at its core it's still very similar
to what you're seeing right now exactly
joy Singh did clients apparently pretty
good at magic all right all right I'm
gonna have to put him on the spot if I
see you in there you go
heard you're good at magic do you
believe in magic yes sure I think good
magic is really cool I don't know what I
classify as good magic I just I think
it's a cool like entertained like cool
form of entertainment I've never paid
for like a like a legitimate magic show
though yeah it's all I did really like
that one show I don't remember feels
like Fox or whatever but oh we're trying
to get out it was the the the guy that
showed you how they did the tricks the
guy in the mask have you seen that one
mmm it's like a second recurring or it
was a TV series where basically a guy
was exposing magic and like how the
tricks work and how they like trick you
interesting and I thought it was cool
forget what it's called exactly but I'm
sure people in chat know what I'm
talking about Clayton says I didn't dig
any of the pre-sequel characters really
Borland's 2 was my favorite yeah that
pre-sequel had some good stuff to it but
it also had some stuff that I was kind
of like yeah I don't like the oxygen
mechanic that game had it was breaking
the magician's code yeah he was that's
why he was hiding in the mass so that
nobody would know and look for him oh
yeah oh that's his favorite that's
Joey's favorite all right cyber ninja
how would you compare Borland's to and
the pre-sequel oh I ultimately I think
choose the better game I think has a
better level design like I said don't
like the oxygen mechanic stuff the only
thing I really think two or pre-sequel
does right is that it added more like
dialogue characterization to the
playable characters
they actually like to talk to each other
and I thought that was a good change
that was kind of it like ultimately
police equals it's not a bad game it's
just got whatever to me I I wasn't like
in love with it or anything and like I
said a couple of the design was Michael
what was your question I saw that you
said I have a question also says I love
Borderlands yeah so it is breaking the
magician's code Magic's biggest secrets
finally revealed its how many series oh
it's on Netflix now so if you want to
catch up on that you can 18 episodes of
him showing you how magic how to how to
basically screw over other magicians
dang although I like the the one movie
man not the prestige is very good and
I'm sure sure magic but there was the
other one oh the one with like Jesse
Eisenberg yeah the second one was not
very good I didn't watch the first one
was good though the first one was good
yeah that was like a fun yeah yeah I
forget what it's called help me Joe now
yeah yeah yeah I think that's correct
now you see me that's called the nasty
magician
no joke oh saved maybe maybe not 164
health fight for your life I got it I
got it
oh that reload animation oh yeah see
there we go
let's get back a little bit get some
health back they also get one about
wrestling - oh really I've never watched
that one wrestle fun [ __ ] WrestleMania
this weekend okay
oh yeah
how about the illusionist I don't recall
watching Edward Norton yeah I like that
one
okay maybe I need a while that's over
that Norton I like that one
they gave him out around with the same
time as the prestige oh yeah yeah I had
to pick one I created the prestige yeah
a precision bail hugh jackman prestige
is the better movie but the illusionist
is by no means a bad film it okay it was
just bad timing I think it's just bad
timing god you can't really compete with
the prestige is so good
David saying given off I think sorry for
booking me on us and if I did nice
evening to was a missed opportunity
I agree I really I don't know I enjoyed
the first one and I was hoping for
I don't know sequels are always hard
though right I feel like I don't know
it's tough to kind of nail that second
one
I mean cuz like even if you try to think
about just like sequels in general like
which ones were really that good and
it's like you know some ants bug life
predicament or alright the two volcano
movies that came out at the same time
wasn't there like Armageddon and deep
impact D Armageddon in deep impact -
meteorite movies yeah time and there
were two volcano movies it was like was
one of them with Pierce Brosnan maybe it
was like Pompeii all right it's like
we're the like cities are like basically
getting into volcano that is so funny
when that happens okay one is
straight-up volcano surf okay now is
that the one with what's is it Tommy Lee
Jones Dante's Peak and Dante's Peak yeah
that tastes feet yeah and there was
Pompeii but I think volcano was volcano
and Dante's Peak with its here at the
same time
yeah see Dante's Peak where's volcano
yeah volcano is Tommy Lee Jones oh wow
Dante's Peak had um I don't know the
actresses name but it's Sarah Connor
from Terminator oh and here's bra slurs
interesting I watched volcano I did not
watch Dante's Peak same with a deep
impact arm again I watched Armageddon I
did not watch
dee pimpin ever watch skeet and then
with the indications are not very good I
watched prestige and not the illusionist
and I owned the prestige actually
alright thought that because it was just
very good it was weird examples I think
like to Cinderella movies came out at
the same time as well like Dante's Peak
was the better movie really oh wow joey
volcano is the number one volcano movie
of all time fact I couldn't tell you I
never saw I watched volcano I did not
watch the event back but Bob Jones
swears by Deep Impact apparently really
yeah okay back then you could only
afford one so I guess so Joe volcano
that's a different Joe versus the
volcano zone well they had tombstone and
wider okay
I watched tombstone did not watch wider
two stones pretty
it's the one without yeah that's got um
Val Kilmer cheese stones got Kurt
Russell right I believe so yeah and then
yeah that's a good one too if you guys
haven't watched it Val Kilmer was what's
a watchin we call it God my huckleberry
why can't I play this on PC so you
should be able to if you can find that
other version only original version it
should be called Borderlands Game of the
Year enhanced yeah and that is what will
be in your Steam library so look for
that so Kurt Russell in Tombstone was
Wyatt Earp and then Bal coma was Doc
Holliday and then Wyatt Earp was and who
is actual whiter was it wasn't that um
what's his name Kevin yeah Kevin Costner
yeah yeah did they come out 1994 for
wider and tombstone was 93 so tombstone
had a had a kind of slight edge like a
winner fiery death nailed it
did it it's okay it's all this like
movie comparison talk
it's all we're down
anyone seen the Joker teaser trailer
it's another like a full-on trailer it's
not easy that's the full trailer yeah we
were just talking about it before we
started the stream actually did an
interesting trailer yeah it's definitely
a kind of dark in the sense that like
it's like real-life dark yeah I'm
curious if that's people are interested
in that because for me I was like well I
think if this came out like around the
like Batman Christopher Nolan era we're
like where's the darkness was set yeah I
think I would have been like way more
into it and now like the tone for
current subaru movies is so like
light-hearted and i kind of prefer that
at least right now mm-hmm i don't know
if it's just like it's not the right
time for a movie like this yeah oh no
see well see I want to dismiss it or
anything
Sam Weaver you can play co-op a split
screen on console you can't but two
co-op here you'd have to like be online
together right it's called teaser to a
trailer about oh okay teaser trailer to
me is like 30 seconds yeah like 34
seconds it's like the one that gets you
to like be hyped that there is a trailer
coming 100% and like today's trailer was
like over two minutes looks like to me
is anything a properties because it
basically like told a story yeah like
that trailer told the story it informed
you of like what to expect from this
movie essentially right or like maybe
without giving everything away but it it
kind of has like a start and an end to
it so I don't know to me that was a
trailer I agree I think it fit my
definition of a full trailer but I guess
they were technically referring to it as
a teaser trailer I wonder what the logic
behind that is there's so many like it
is called teaser trailer um weird
marketing reasons for why it's called
the trailers like I feel like at some
point though I gotta stop watching
trailers like even for like Avengers and
games like there's been so many trailers
and I just have to stop watching them at
some point because it's like man you're
giving stuff away but they also do the
thing where they have like cutscenes I
feel like the throw you off and then
they don't actually make it into the
movie yeah
but yeah the one there's that pretty
famous one in the last of injuries
we're like it [ __ ] they showed the hole
in the tall yeah in the that will kind
of fight and what kind of fight but then
using the Hulkbuster I don't know if
that was like a cut thing or if they
actually intentionally like did that to
throw people off yeah uh cactii guy you
can buy this game on xbox but it's
$29.99 whereas if PC you own Borderlands
1 already you're just kind of like
updating or like downloading the proper
version are you out of planning so many
guys oh my god
checksum needs good now that excuse me
hello there this guy can just eat
grenades I guess alright what's going on
to week 2 guys talk films next week look
forward to book reviews ah I don't know
I mean we didn't really talk about the
game but then you know as chat goes we
also just chat about what Chad's talking
about I guess me and Ben spent like 20
minutes talking about Tom Clancy novels
small replied division sick there you go
if you want book review go watch that
stream come back to GameSpot live Monday
to Friday where we play games but also
do chats about books and trailers and
breakdown and whatever yeah I mean like
the way you guys look at it is that the
stream is centered around the game and
we'll definitely talk about the game and
answer questions about the game but
we're also gonna talk about like things
that are happening in pop culture I mean
it's just part of our daily life Echo's
have you guys noticed any gameplay
changes I think the one thing that you
mentioned is you feel like the weapon
handling is a little bit better I think
so yeah and then so there's definitely
some UI changes and graphically there's
some minor like upgrades yeah
someone's asking no update if you have
the og on Xbox no I'll do the first og
is backwards compatible on xbox but you
won't get like an updated version either
you have to buy an additional box these
enhancements which is the $29.99 which I
said $30 but someone said that's not
true I round it up minimap you up and
scrum point out the mini-map or
something yeah angels difference
angels design more like Borderlands 2
and then a little bit of character
customization with like the head stuff
yeah as Bob Dunn's dreams are alive
thing and things change as they go on
this is true
Scaggs everywhere man
roaring verdict says this is dope I love
this game level 46 right now nice and
then does the remastered version come
with a third and replayable playthrough
like No okay
they did not add a ultimate vault hunter
playthrough just it has the normal
sequence
they do let you import your your
character though so if you had like a
character that was like a in my case I
had a character right beat in the game
with but didn't start a second
playthrough with and that's why I'm 42
import them that's cool glad you figured
it out they're hard where I think
there's a hardware bar are you trying to
find it yeah they said that it was it's
just like he had it in his favorites but
then I think he like obviously the newer
version wasn't like ads are those new
things yeah it's like a separate thing
so you don't see it that makes sense
give me your hands
so threw me off I just saw because
originally my version was just called
Borderlands so I updated inside
Portland's game there I'm like okay
that's it it just updated over it
surprise sprite in hands it's actually
not I turn it on I was like wait a
minute this looks like the exact same
thing
you get on Steam Stefon
yeah there's one of those back here to
your left as well as noting that the
principles call yeah sure had to do it
for your mission objective I do and I've
been doing a policing job
I definitely like twos like the
mechanics they added as far as the
different elemental stuff they put a
bigger emphasis on the manufacture so
like gun manufacturers actually have
different like perks associated with
them so it's like these manufacturers
you know do this kind of garlic this
kind of gunner like they focus on
elemental damage and these kinds of guns
like like bandit guns always have like
those really large magazine size is
their thing so I just found that to be
more interesting where it's like oh you
kind of can like pay attention to a
certain type a certain type and kind of
know what you're looking for
like Jacobs guns were always wooden and
more like high damage but then like you
know kind of like bolt action like first
sized roots and stuff like that
Oh actually hit him from there
no get over here Oh No that is
unfortunate well bar fight for your life
you want to rush this mission uh why I
mean yeah what would it we're pretty
much it told like 1228 sure is there any
thing else that he was curious about I
mean yeah I mean we wrap up the stream
scene if there's something you want to
see or whatever send that through chat
now I know there's some delay so I'll
give it a second it's it's Borderlands
yep stop you know I think revolutionary
it's just more Borderlands one yeah but
well it's also for consoles for consoles
they never got it so so if you've never
played Borderlands 1 and you're
interested I this is a pretty good
opportunity to check it out and if you
party own Borderlands 1 and you want to
replay it it's probably a pretty good
way to do it
maybe get through some playthroughs
before the Borderlands 3 release yeah if
you're excited about that game can't
wait split-screen yeah rip no I'm good
try playing with my girlfriend see if
she likes it I'm sure you could buy it
off the Xbox store tactic I'm sure it's
there yeah [ __ ] and then if you want
physical that's like another there is
physical editions right it is but it's a
Gamestop exclusive and that's fine cuz I
was looking that up I was like oh maybe
I'll pick up a physical copy huh and
then cuz I like getting physical copies
for some games and I couldn't find it
and then I found an article I was like
you have to get it exclusively a game
stop I'm like alright can you reduce HUD
elements now ask a question we can find
out game options trading messages turn
that off yeah there's a lot more show
compass yeah you can turn off compass
mini-map let's turn them off oh you can
just say well the windows key simple
windows key to stable launcher simple
startup movies that's nice
so Borderlands 1 had this thing where
I'm gonna turn it on you would uh it
would make you go through like all the
splash screens like the Nvidia logo on
the gearbox logo and you couldn't skip
them to the point people like actually
made mods so we're like here's how to
get rid of them on PC cuz it's so
annoying so the fact that they added
that is an option is actually nice that
looks like that was it though as far as
what I could remove so it's really just
the HUD you can't are the mini-map you
can't remove are the headshot still the
same as they were in the original
release or - have they censored them
like they did in Borland suum pre-sequel
uh censored them Oh like yeah cuz you
would like they're like heads would
explode they'd have like skulls or
something I don't know I wasn't paying
too much I didn't see any of that if
that's what it's a possible
but I also wasn't totally paying
attention I heard that there were maybe
different versions and different regions
with like Borderlands 2 or something
like you see that they're gonna like
take the sensor off of like doing the
fighting right
oh really I think by reading that
headline property for like which which
regions I have to take a look aggregate
this is remastered didn't it's probably
harder to tell that it looks different
on a screen you'd have to kind of see it
yeah if you just played the original
like I did over the weekend you can
definitely tell away that why the
texture works a little bit sharper they
couldn't stop he said some of the blacks
from the lines yeah are a little bit
bigger the like the reflection on the
scope a lot better but it's relatively
minor changes I mean there is no border
line this is a pretty timeless art style
that holds up pretty well I think I'm
gonna let you fill these two boys yeah
that's a good way to call it
the bloody Palace update action
uncensored a few of the versions okay
boxing's $29.99 is a bit to see for
border labs born and thinks he should
have been like $15.99 I don't even know
when the last time a game was 59 mm
maybe 20 maybe $19.99
yeah we'll see I could see that argument
I mean at the very least it's free on a
pcard younger so there's quality of life
stuff for sure Dell boy gaming the
mini-map as you saw in the top right as
we mentioned some of the gameplay stuff
that we just mentioned as well some of
the menus are updated maybe we won't
fill these units in there being a pain
there we go Burnham oh isn't it what it
just won't stop spawning all right Neal
oh just kidding it's the bad mother
shock alpha yep open wide just hiding
all right well you still gonna kill him
from that burn damage there you go is
this like never-ending common man I
don't know it's like the game telling us
like no no you don't want to stop you
you're gonna keep killing these two
Skaggs forever forever and ever
I'm so confused yeah all right that's
fine I'm turning off thanks everyone for
tuning in to our Borderlands Game of the
Year Edition basically Borderlands
remastered if you have it on PC on Steam
you just have to upload or now play
update or download basically the
enhanced version even though your says
game of the Year Edition it's actually
not unless you see kind of in the
parentheses the enhanced has fov
mini-map angel looks different some of
the you said some of the gameplay in
terms of like shooting felt a little bit
better yeah a lot of the quality of life
improvements they brought to the PC
versions of like - as far as like
graphical stuff they seem to have
included in this one so I think it just
feels a little bit better
nice good yeah awesome well come back
tomorrow we'll be back at 11:00 a.m. as
normal you'll be back 11 a.m. on Friday
- as you guys continue your journey
through
Mortal Kombat playing through all the
Mortal Kombat game 411 comes out which
is in 20 days or so so like three weeks
I think I'm playing dead cells tomorrow
but we'll see anything anything things
change
you never know keep you on your toes
thanks so much I like any last thoughts
Borderlands nope seems pretty good cool
check it out if you want to its out
peace